New Hampshire we're live free or die is
a legitimately difficult choice it has
always held a special place in American
politics and earlier this month some
local fourth graders visited the State
Capitol to learn how government worked
as part of a civics project a group of
fourth-graders including nine-year-old
Maya Roca crafted a bill to make the
red-tailed hawk the official state
Raptor mr. cuttings fourth grade class
arrived in the house gallery to watch
their bill come up for a vote
they were agreed by enthusiastic
applause well that's fantastic what a
great opportunity for the kids to engage
in the political process and be inspired
I can only presume that their state
Raptor bill sailed right through we
already have a state bird but now do we
need a state Raptor isn't that a bird
isn't that an animal so are we gonna
have you know flightless birds waterfowl
pet birds garden birds wild birds how
many of these bills do we need to have
if we keep bringing more of these bills
and bills and bills forward that really
I feel we shouldn't have in front of us
we'll be picking a state hot dog next
what is wrong with you hey this doesn't
matter be the children are in the room
and see this doesn't matter just vote
yes and make them happy and sadly the
story didn't end there because state
representative Warren grown also decided
it was appropriate to use the red-tailed
hawk to make a completely unnecessary
point it's known for its extremely
strong and sharp talons with which is
grasped its prey but it grass Sims with
its talons and then uses this
razor-sharp beak to rip its victim to
shreds and to basically tear it apart
limb by limb and I guess the shame about
making this a state birders it would
serve as a much better mascot for
Planned Parenthood
what the are you talking about from
start Prescott
everyone knows Planned Parenthood
already has a mascot it's Plan B the
Planned Parenthood ring hey guys did you
hear the buzz on spermicidal lubricant
No thank you Barbie you're the best and
this wasn't just a few cranks the
legislature actually defeated the
children's bill 133 to 160 and
presumably then celebrated by looking up
at the kids and saying nice try idiots
by the way Santa's not real and Dora the
Explorer can't hear you now this must
have been devastating for the kids but
if their stupid state government will
not properly honor the red-tailed hawk
then we will and that is why the
red-tailed hawk is the official rapper
of last week's and nights in fact here
it is a real way predatory Hawk and a
television studio and to show just how
wrong New Hampshire legislators were to
deny those fourth graders from Lincoln
Ackerman school their red-tailed hawk
request we've prepared this red-tailed
Hawks
the official Raptors of last week
tonight why because the ephedra walk
walk they'll take out a rattlesnakes big
killer shell on a basketball heroin then
they'll feed their baby but wait that's
not all they'll grab a pheasant while
doing a mid-air three six days let's
watch that again
but don't just take it from us here's
some red tailed hawk facts from a guy in
the 90s red-tailed Hawks found all over
North America
probably the most common bird of prey in
the u.s. this guy's incredible
give me more hawk facts man most of the
books estimate they're grasping strength
is about 200 pounds per square inch of
pressure for the stooping speed for the
red tail here is about a hundred to 120
miles an hour and all this is why the
red-tailed hawk is last week tonight
official Raptor Raptor scream
congratulations fulbrighters balls Oh
Oh
you